we've just had a massive news dump about
all the new sets dropping in the first
half of 2024 Outlaws at Thunder Junction
modern Horizons 3 universes Beyond
Assassin's Creed and Bloom Haven so
without further Ado let's jump into it
starting with Outlaws of Thunder
Junction Magic's First Western theme set
we finally got all the details on
exactly what OKO is up to and the crew
he's pulled together thanks to the omen
Pass opening up after the fian invasion
Thunder Junction has now been connected
to the rest of the Multiverse and OKO
has discovered that at the heart of
Thunder Junction there is an unopened
Vault that contains unimaginable wealth
and treasures so of course he plans to
pull off the biggest heist in the whole
of the Multiverse let's meet the team
he's pulled together first there's the
ring leader himself OKO represented with
his own new Plains Walker card a four
minor simic three loyal Plains Walker
that has the triggered ability at the
beginning of combat on your turn OKO the
ring leader becomes a copy of up to one
target creature you control until end of
turn except he has hex proof for plus
one you get to draw two cards and if
you've committed a crime this turn
discard a card otherwise discard two
cards we'll talk more about crimes
shortly and what that means for the game
his negative one simply creates a 33
Green Elk token and his ultimate for
minus five for each other non-land
permanent you control create a token
that's a copy of that permanent drawing
cards and creating blockers has always
been a key trait of powerful Plaines
Walkers so be sure to keep your eye on
this one as far as committing crimes go
this is a new batch mechanic that is
similar to Historic and modify historic
for example simply refers to cards or
tokens that are artifacts sagas or
anything with the legendary subtype to
commit a crime you simply need to have a
spell or an ability either Target your
opponent or anything they control which
includes spells permanence cards in
their hand cards in their library or
cards in their graveyard so thought
seizing your opponent that's a crime
countering one of their spells that's a
crime turning someone's Commander into
an elk you better believe that's a crime
Commander players can relax though
crimes need to Target something this
means that Wizards have confirmed that
Armageddon farewell and torment of
Hailfire for 50 are not crimes moving on
to the rest of the crew we've got
another preview with tiny Bones the
pickpocket a legendary 1 one for one
with dep touch that when it deals combat
damage to a player you can cast an
nonland card from that player's
graveyard and because this ability
targets it's a crime the last of the
crew members are verasa the silencer
ratos the muscle
newcomer Annie Flash the veteran and
what apparently is his final Adventure
Kellen the
kid two final things for Thunder
Junction there are two bonus sheets with
this set that can be found in all
boosters the first is being the breaking
news sheet which features a number of
reprints that will all trigger the crime
mechanic thought seiz and crime and
punishment are the first two previewed
in addition to the crime cards you can
also find wanted posted variants of the
crew these crime cards are guaranteed to
appear in every
booster the last bonus sheet is known as
the Big Score these are effectively
placing the list slot in boosters
thematically these are the goodies that
are likely to be locked away in the
Thunder Junction Vault this sheet
features 40 brand new standard legal
cards the first of which is a new sword
sword of wealth and power power it
follows the same layout as the previous
versions it's a three minor equipment
with equi two it gives the equipped
creature plus two plus two and has
protection from instance and sorceries
and when the creature deals combat
damage to a player you create a treasure
token and you get to twincast your next
instant or
sorcery one last card that was revealed
fibble FIB lost on the Range a three
Manor blue 1 one that mentions a new
mechanic called
plot judging from what we've seen on the
commander boxes I imagine this has
something to do with playing cards face
down as lands but I'll update you once
we find out Thunder Junction previews
start on March 26 and pre-release kicks
off on April 12th next we got an
in-depth look at what's to come with
universes Beyond Assassin's Creed the
team have confirmed that this set is
going to be 100 cards 80 of which will
be brand new new and 20 of them will be
reprints it will include characters from
every single Assassin's Creed game
starting with four iconic cards we have
Etso Altier the hidden blade and the
Animus the Etso card also shows off a
new mechanic free running extremely
similar to the prow mechanic from
Morning Tide back in 2008 free running
says you may cast a spell for its free
running cost if you dealt combat damage
to a player this turn with an assassin
or a
commander it's also worth noting that
because Etso has the five Mana symbols
in his finishing blow ability he can be
a five-color commander for your
Assassin's deck we also got to look at
three of the reprints temporal trespass
cover of darkness and sword of feast and
famine as don't forget this set is legal
in modern now what I personally think is
the craziest reveal of this set is the
fact that we're getting four real life
historic figures being printed in this
set the first two are Leonardo da Vinci
and Cleopatra exiled
Pharaoh these cards will be printed in
borderless art as well as a serialized
version which will also be printed in
the characters home language Italian for
Leonardo da Vinci and Greek for
Cleopatra of course there's a bunch of
different art treatments for the other
cards but we must end on my favorite
card of the day Hy
stack Assassin's Creed previews start on
June 18th and the set will be launching
with Beyond boosters collector boosters
and a starter kit on July
5th moving on to Modern Horizon's 3 news
we got some big confirmations firstly
the double face cards that were hinted
at previously have been announced to be
a cycle of Plaines Walker Origins
similar to the ones we got from the
magic Origins set these double face
cards aim to tell the story of of how a
plaines Walker got their spark a Johnny
was revealed at the event a white one
two for two that creates a 2-1 cat token
and whenever one or more other cats dies
Fs in chat for ajani's brother Exile
aani and return him transformed aani
flips into aani nikato Avenger a red
white three loyalty Plains Walker with
some interesting
abilities it was also confirmed that
tamio would be getting a transforming
card too
now before the story buff asks didn't we
lose tamio in The forian Invasion well
yes we did modern Horizon sets don't
progress the overall main story they are
cards presenting points in time which
brings us to our next card emerle the
world a new a 12 Mana 1212 that says
when you cast this spell gain control of
all creatures Target player controls it
has flying protection from spells and
permanence that will cast this turn and
when emerle the world of new leaves the
battlefield sacrifice All Creatures you
control it also has Madness for six
colorless Mana Madness is the special
ability that says if you were to discard
this card you may Exile it and then cast
it for its Madness cost so with a simple
looting ability you could be casting the
new emerle for just six Mana that
protection ability is not to be
underrated too it stops plains walkers
that are usually deployed to stop
threats like this it stops the other
popular lay line binding and Solitude
any creatures with haste it can easily
block as well as targeted instants or
sorceries if you do happen to face one
of these on the battlefield otara or
wrath of God will certainly do the trick
to help you out here and while yes she
can be countered that gain control of
creatures ability Triggers on cast so be
mindful of that we also got a first look
at some other brand new cards including
one of the cycle of new free spells a
throwback to the aogs of old days and
confirmation that energy is making a
return it was also announced that priest
of Tania and leeli the blade reforge
will also become modern legal and of
course we got the confirmation that
Allied fetch lands will be coming to
Modern Horizons 32 one final strange
announcement
turns out we're getting modern Horizon 3
Commander decks and not only that we're
getting collector editions of the
commander deck 2 we'll go over these in
more detail at a later date modern
Horizon previews start on May 21st and
pre-release kicks off on June
7th for the final block of announcements
we got a detailed look at what to expect
from Bloom Haven Bloom Haven is an all
animal plane and will be focused around
these six Heroes as they look to battle
large beasts known as the
calamities our main protagonist is mael
air to crank
flame a three Mana 33 Mouse soldier that
Buffs other mice she also comes with the
legendary crack flame equipment joining
mael we have gev scaled Scorch hugs
Grizzly Guardian Phineas Ace Archer and
zorine Cosmo Calla I have no idea why we
didn't learn this guy's name but Wizards
did go on to show us a couple of
familiar faces that will be making an
appearance Mabel and the party will band
together to take on calamities like
lumara Bellow of the woods as well as
Maha its feathers
night of course with this set being so
adorable it goes without saying that
there will be adorable alternative art
cards coming
to bloom Haven will be launching with
the typical slew of products including
four Commander decks and a starter deck
Bloom Haven previews start on July 9th
with pre-release starting on July
26th okay that's all the key information
you need to know about the upcoming sets
I'll be making more videos on these sets
closer to release date what are you most
looking forward to as always be sure to
like the video If you learned something
and sub subscribe or else I'll unlock
the eldrazi prison on Bloom Haven thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next one